carrying on from
the observation
we all observe at times I think it
doesn't matter where I've been in the
world you'll get students they perhaps
late for class but they want to be there
so they watch class or you know perhaps
yourself you've had an injury you still
go to class you sit on the
on the edge of the mat
and you watch the teacher show the
techniques the students get out and they
perform the techniques the teacher walks
over
to the student because they are part of
the class so you make conversation
and the one question I've had
over all the years I've been teaching
and the don't matter what country I've
been in the question is the same
essentially why are they not doing what
we've just shown
and it's very odd that um
when we're an observer
we see something completely different to
what the students do who have actually
training on the map
I don't know why this is a phenomena I
don't know why it happens but it happens
so
I encourage you all at times to be an
observer
when you look at films or Masters
whether it be on the map off the mat
try to do
perhapsely make yourself an observer
you know so when you're looking at what
they're doing try to not sort of look as
if you're trying to absorb knowledge but
look as if
and I shouldn't maybe be saying the
Casual look but look look at it like you
would in your home if you're looking at
a YouTube film of a master or just a
seminar
and you'll notice that the people are
doing all sorts of different uh things
within the Aikido
that brings me to don't expect me or any
environment teacher come to that to look
the same
we're not a Sausage Factory
we don't all come out exactly the same
over and over we're individuals we have
our ancestors our genes and that's what
makes us individuals
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to get the structure of the techniques
and the techniques we put into our
understanding are being the way we move
and the way we think okay so it's a way
of learning and trying to get closer
so today the observation is when I watch
teachers in particular practice
and I suggest any of you do always do
the partner practices until it becomes
like a very smooth
timing is good with your partner
the space is correct the the attacks are
in the correct place on the head
ultimate sternum
the idea of the thrust is you're trying
to stop the Heart by giving it a thumb
whether it be with a job or a Ken
because it's not a soul remember it's
not a sword it's just the shape of a
sword
so my observation is I'll see people you
know that
um about I've taped their sword and they
draw it like this as if they're drawing
it out in a scaven and and then like
this but look at me I might be correct
but I'm stiff
and I'm not relaxed at all you know yes
it might look good to the to the people
looking on this yeah it's not real and
that's what I'm trying to say so
yeah buy yourself a nice Ken
not a cheap can those two lights and not
one that is too heavy if you do get the
rare chance of selecting cans just keep
selecting them see what they feel like
in your hands you know
see where the balance is
the balance maybe here it could be here
you know if it doesn't suit you the same
as
yeah he wouldn't in my case I like
watches I wouldn't buy a watch just
because it tells the time I have to
enjoy it I have to look at it I have to
look at it and know that I'm going to
enjoy it for years to come
perhaps I'm over the top like that